Hello and welcome
back to what I guess
I'm going to call our interlude
between Chapter 1 and Chapter
2.
Since I've started recording
our first battery of videos,
a number of things have changed.
And so I just want
to touch on those
before we get into Chapter 2.
The first and most obvious
thing you'll notice
is that I am now using Xcode 5.
And my guess is you're
going to be using it, too.
And for most of the
stuff moving forward,
I'm going to be testing
on iOS 7 devices.
So that's the first
and biggest change.
The second is that we've
upgraded both the Google+
the Google Play Games SDKs since
that we first launched these
videos.
In Google+ land, we are
now using SDK version 1.4.
And on Google Play Games,
we're now using version 1.2.
If you've used older version
of either of these libraries,
you're going to need to
download the new versions
of these libraries
and install them.
And I actually need
to do that here,
so I'm going to show
you how I do it.
It turns out that,
at least in my case,
upgrading frameworks
and bundles within Xcode
is-- it causes
some issues for me.
I've never had good luck
with this Xcode suddenly
seems to forget what my
GPG manager is, and can't
seem to find it.
And I run into a
lot of odd issues.
And as counter intuitive
as it might seem,
I've actually had
much better luck
if I update these frameworks
just using Finder.
So I'm going to do that.
So first thing we
are going to do,
I'm going to close
this project in Xcode.
Next up, I'm going to
open up a Finder window
where my project is located.
And now, I'm going to
download the updated
version of each of
these libraries.
So let me open up Chrome here.
And first, I'm going to go to
developers.google.com/games/services/downloads.
By the time you see
this video, this
should now say Games SDK
version 1.2, or maybe 1.2.1.
And click on this
link to download it.
And then you can go to
developers.google.com/plus/downloads
to download the updated version
of the Google+ SDK for iOS.
And I'm going to
download it here.
And you can see it's telling
me I have SDK version 1.4.1.
So now, I'm going to go
into my Downloads folder.
And here we can
see the new SDKs.
Let's extract this zip.
And this will probably
say 1.2, not 1.2.beta.
And now we can replace
the frameworks.
So here's what I'm going to do.
It's pretty straightforward.
First, let's do the Google+ SDK.
So I'm going to go into
my Guess My number folder,
or wherever it turns out
Xcode has copied the framework
folders for you.
In my case, it's right here.
I'm going to delete
these two frameworks.
There we go.
Just the two frameworks.
And I'm going to
copy them over again
within Finder into
the same location.
And then I'm going
to the same thing
with my Play Games services
framework and bundle.
Delete it.
And then two copy
these two over.
There we go.
Again, I know this seems a
little counter intuitive.
We're sort of
swapping up frameworks
under the feed of Xcode.
And it doesn't seem to
know that it's happening.
But if you open up this
project again in Xcode,
it seems to handle these
changes pretty elegantly,
which is nice.
Now once that's done, if you
try to compile this thing,
you'll probably get
a number of errors.
Yep.
And it looks like it's
stuff that looks like this.
And that's because the new
Google+ SDK requires four more
frameworks for us to add.
So we'll go into these.
And so the first thing we're
going to add is Core Motion.
There we go.
We're also going to
add Core Location.
Next we're going to
add Assets Library.
And finally, we're going
to add Media Player.
All right, once those four new
frameworks have been added,
the SDK should
compile correctly.
Let's run it and
see what happens.
No issues.
Build succeeded.
That's good.
And there we go.
Everything seems to be
working, although you
might notice an odd
little error, which
is that our title
has now disappeared
underneath this
Navigation controller.
And in fact, if I click Easy,
to go into an easy game,
you'll see that the
instructions I can't really
see because it's hidden
behind this somewhat
translucent
navigation controller.
Now this is happening
because, well, I
did not follow the recommended
protocol and start using
auto-layout when it
first became available.
And right now
somebody in Cupertino
is laughing at me
saying, yeah, you
thought you were so smart
ignoring the recommendations.
But who's laughing now?
Huh, huh, tough guy?
So if you are using
on auto-layout,
this probably doesn't
happen to you.
In my situation,
there does happen
to be a pretty
easy way to fix it.
And that involves
using these new iOS 6.7
deltas that you see right here.
So here is what
we're going to do.
Here's how this works.
I'm going to switch over
to my File Inspector.
And I'm going to say, I want
to view this nib as an iOS 6.1
layout.
Everything's
looking good so far.
And now I want to select this
label and these three buttons,
go back to the Size
inspector, and here I'm
going to set the delta y to 60.
And that means place these
objects here, for now,
in iOS 6.
But when you switched to
iOS 7, moves them down
by about 60 points.
Hit Return.
And now, when I run this,
we'll see that, in iOS 7,
the Guess My Number label,
as well as these buttons,
have now been moved down
underneath the navigation
controller bar here.
And if I were to
run this in iOS 6,
they are still back in
their original location.
So this is one
work around, if you
find yourself running
into the same issues
once you've switched to iOS 7.
And we can do the same thing
in the game view controller.
Here, I'm going to
select, actually,
just about everything here.
Make sure I'm viewing
it as iOS 6.1.
And then we go back
to my size inspector
and set the delta y to 60.
And that will have
this one fixed as well.
So if I go back to
iOS 7 and run this,
everything is now placed
properly-- on an iOS 7 device.
And so with that, we are
now fully modernized.
We're using Xcode 5,
iOS 7, using version 1.4
of the Google+ SDK,
or, I guess, 1.4.1,
and using version 1.2
of the Play Games SDK.
And who knows.
Maybe by the time
you see this video,
we'll even be at
a higher version.
But there you go.
With that, we're
now all set to go.
And we can start
looking at achievements,
which we'll do in
the next lesson.